a moment of reflection for the hundred
and seventy-six victims of flight PS 7-5
to countries United in grief together in
the British capital they're demanding
accountability compensation and eventual
closure Canada lost 57 people its
emerged as a leading voice in the fight
for justice many many questions answers
all of the countries assembled here
today want answers and the international
community wants answered the world is
waiting for those answers
and until we give them Iran initially
denied responsibility for the crash
blaming technical failure but later
admitted that it shot down the aircraft
mistaking it for a US cruise missile it
happened several hours after Iran
launched a ballistic missile strike
against US forces in Iraq in response to
the US drone killing of top Iranian
general Qasim soleimani and
investigations now underway in Iran
experts from several countries have been
allowed to provide technical assistance
in the probe Ukrainian experts are
analyzing the planes black box data
recorders but so far few details have
been released getting to the heart of
what happened to flight PS 75 - will
require cooperation between all of the
countries involved but in recent days
rhetoric surrounding Iran's
controversial nuclear program has
escalated and now the UK France and
Germany are threatening new sanctions
against the country the deal was agreed
in 2015 to limit the country's nuclear
capabilities in return for lifting
economic sanctions Washington withdrew
from the agreement in 2018 Iran's been
dropping its commitments ever since and
is now enriching more uranium than
before the nuclear deal responding to
the threat of fresh sanctions president
Hassan rouhani said European soldiers in
the Middle East could be in danger this
tense political climate of mutual
distrust and suspicion could hamper
investigators working together to
establish how and
why so many lives were lost Nev Barker
al-jazeera London